it's not even about punishing people or
fairness
i think that the approach in some other
areas is anti-innovation
there are products that do not pay does
like um
paying people's dmv fees where we just
pay
you don't have to send the check do not
pages you pay do not pay and they
we pay and don't charge anything more um
in san francisco you can't do that
because san francisco says
money's thrown flowing through you you
have to pay 0.5 percent to us
not even on profit on revenue it's quite
a new gross receipts tax
i don't know but and that's so literally
because you're a company
that is processing a payment even though
you make no money yes
they say you make no money but we as the
city we're going to make money
we'll make 0.5 just for you to be here
and it's not 0.5
of the san francisco tickets is 0.5 of
everywhere even if we were operating in
cape town south africa we'd have to pay
0.5
to san francisco so if a user in cape
town south africa
wants to basically pay a parking ticket
in
cape town south africa san francisco
believes that they have a right to 0.5
of that transaction that's right and
this was the last move for us
um i was trying to justify being in san
francisco but when we got this big tax
bill from 2020 for gross receipts
i was like okay enough is enough that's
[ __ ] nuts
it really is are you gonna pay it well
uh
we're discussing that i think to be
honest reluctantly
we'll pay it but we'll never give them a
single dollar again yeah
i mean that's like to me i've heard some
pretty egregious things in these cities
do
that may be up there it's one of the
most egregious things yeah and it's not
just do not pay
anything related to fintech has these
problems so it holds back innovation
and so uh stripe being based in san
francisco around san francisco wherever
their headquarters is
do they have to do a similar thing where
they have to pay point five percent to
uh the city of san francisco for every
single transaction that they process
um so there are exemptions for credit
card companies
so if you're truly an incumbent industry
like maybe they've come up with an
exemption but even stripe has moved out
of san francisco to daly city or
somewhere
because of this tax really so they
basically they
levy attacks which they think is going
to lead to more revenue but what it's
done instead is it's driven
one of the most valuable private
technology companies in the world
out of their city drove you out of the
city i can't
begin to imagine how many other
companies have left the city all because
of this stupid tax
yeah and fair enough on profits but
revenue is ridiculous and it
is only increasing agreed i think that's
i think that's the egregious part
right it's not so much that there is a
tax it's that the tax is on gross
revenue
not on any profit and therefore they
want to get paid even if you don't make
money
yeah and the question we ask is what do
we get in return and the only thing we
get in return is restrictions right
last year we couldn't open our business
because of covert restrictions where
miami is completely open
so not only is it not a net positive
it's actually a net benefit
negative